you can't just buy a legacy you have to
build it he's gonna win it out now but
so difficult so I'm hot
zero the the start of the Year wasn't as
strong and you know we had to deviate
from our plans a little bit well you
have to index a lot in the confidence if
you're EG right now they have that
inexperienced player that we keep
talking about in Demon one and the
narrative around this team is it they're
going to be 10th place we did not think
we're gonna make it into playoffs you
know they needed mibr to beat hundred
thieves which no one thought was gonna
happen
mibr now gives him the gift to just see
what they can make of this Potter this
is where she comes in huge
here dude they're doing this on their
own talk about feeling themselves
no one had eye expectations for the
squad but they turned things around came
up with new ideas and started taking
wins over teams way higher in the
standings than that look at everyone go
for it I want it I want
the pressure was all of a sent off like
we didn't even expect to be here every
single week you just saw Improvement and
Improvement and Improvement and now
they're here
to out for a Chronicle to try and get
fnatic across the line oh my God
he's just save them but it's Alpha up
against even though oh my God
before we get into Potter's remarkable
Journey Don't forget to hit the like
button the Subscribe button and to ring
that notification Bell that way you will
never miss another hype video about a
Cinderella run okay so you may know
Potter as evil genius's valorant coach
what you might not realize is that she
turned a joke team into an international
threat and silenced the doubters who
refuse to believe she could do it you
see before becoming a coach Potter was
attack FPS Legend she kicked her
professional career off back in 2006
competing in CS 1.6 for SK Gaming's
women's division SK ladies and by 2007
she took home her first world title at
eswc Paris
foreign
Potter and her team became a Dynasty on
the women's CS circuit lifting five more
World trophies between 2008 to 2015. and
Potter used that success to become an
ambassador for the women's scene there
are some women out there right now some
girls who could be 17 years old and they
could be the exception they might be
good and it's my responsibility to allow
these women to be inspired to understand
that they can take it to the next level
they can't dream in 2018 Potter looked
to a new challenge joining Giuliano on
res Gaming's European roster I feel very
confident that we are gonna win I think
that's one of the main factors of why I
joined this team they had a a really
long-standing winning culture and I
definitely wanted to be a part of it
however her time at res was short-lived
she returned home after only six months
ultimately marking the end of her
playing career Potter then moved to the
analyst desk joining blast pro series
after her old roommate Moses encouraged
her to give it a try Jason's got
connections so he got me my first gig
and it was quite the gig it was not like
a small gig this was in Istanbul it was
a huge event last Premiere series and I
was just like holy moly I didn't realize
what I was doing and I was there and it
was just like this huge imposter
syndrome right away I think the fear of
failure is always going to be there but
you just gotta do it and if you fail you
fail despite being self-admittedly
camera shy Potter continued working as
an analyst at various CS go events
throughout 2018 and 2019 but then she
picked up valorant Wright's new FPS
reignited Potter's competitive fire she
wanted to play and win and so she signed
with Evil Geniuses mixed roster in early
2021 as the team's igl unfortunately EG
just weren't winning after failing to
qualify to Challengers multiple times
they had to make some changes EG moved
to a fully male roster taking Potter off
the lineup but her years of competitive
experience were still extremely valuable
to the team so they made her the new
head coach under Potter the new EG
became known as a very Innovative team
with unique set plays and utility combos
but all that Innovation didn't mean much
if the team couldn't win EG didn't make
a single International Event in 2022 so
when they were selected as one of
Wright's 10 orgs to the Americas League
everyone expected them to blow up their
roster as more and more teams announced
their star signings EG stayed quiet and
the community assumed they'd fall behind
everyone else they were getting meme
done pretty much all over social media
fans were calling for EG to remove
certain players from their roster but
behind the scenes Potter believed in her
team she knew they could compete with
the best so despite all the hate coming
from the community EG retained their
core of bustio com and jojomo heading
into the 2023 season and added Ethan and
bcj who offer some much needed Land
Experience unfortunately at the very
first land event of the Season EG
crumbled so just trying to draw those
rotations that's the name of the game
right now for EG flash over the top
though and Sushi Boys still watching
from Heaven flick of the rest and he
finds one more Target and still there's
just no time EG denied in another
comeback completed Talon will move
forwards and after that loss at lock-in
things only got worse two versus two
it's not Planet here for EG this could
get dangerous right now finally outside
from the aim shotgun onto the ground
will the second one land it will not
waiting
dude
[Music]
and all they want to do here is just
push that space back there's no
opportunity to break that lockdown
if he wants to and they both fall 100 of
these comes in for
[Applause]
this we're so bad that people began
ranking EG as one of the worst teams in
the entire league things were Beginning
to Look truly dire for Potter and EG
they didn't win a single map in those
first two matches and so they needed to
turn things around fast it didn't help
that some members of the community were
now questioning whether Potter was the
right person for the job but what Potter
did next shook the entire valorant world
on April 15th EG announced that they
were benching fan favorite bcj in favor
of demon one this was a controversial
Choice from the outside looking in bcj
wasn't the problem if anything EG were
just struggling to close out games and
it didn't help that the person they
replaced him with played a completely
different role however demon 1 ended up
being exactly what EG needed
falling good from Ethan shots better
from DG
oh my God oh my gosh what was that
right
how one enemy he's not done man it's all
a setup it's all a setup for the blades
there it is demon one gets all five by
the end of their season Potter had EG
looking like playoff contenders except
there was one big problem their shot at
Redemption would come down to chance if
EG wanted to make playoffs they needed
mibr the new worst team in the league to
beat hundred thieves and mibr was
playing with their assistant coach as a
sub for this series it didn't look good
for EG they basically accepted that they
weren't making playoffs but then the
unthinkable happened
at this point the longer you take to
make this decision of whether or not you
want to go towards A or B it's a cut
noise you're going to be landing on B we
are still sitting here stunned as well
all the utility is being laid awkwardly
all on a strike no way collapsed into
him tulips standing it would have to be
a miracle left down to the final few
seconds here's the tower fighting to be
won by Ashley he doesn't do it no
detainment swing it wide
13-6 up one what up I am ABR 100 thieves
you gotta collect the kills with the
utility chosen he's blocked them off
it's a scramble everything on the line
for it you gotta stick at chosen Sprague
try to die no way off of it all he's the
hero in the scenario and a hundred
thieves have been denied
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean it did feel like a miracle we
were all typing in the chat it was
intense it definitely
felt surreal luck was on their side and
brought Potter's EG Squad to playoffs
they had a shot at flipping the script
and making everyone realize how wrong
they were for doubting them and they did
not waste the opportunity
it connects artist holes connecting onto
more and he spots two players in the top
of heaven so Dragon Ball and Eve that
are both being pinned trying to stay
alive around the generators to battle
inside the smoke jargon was still in the
back trying to spray across once again
seems to Barrel the goodness up couldn't
ask something to crashes
are back there's 10 seconds left
and EG are up at 11. Ethan's already
watching Ford
and he does not get the kill the crash
his position is now given away
you need Herculean efforts right now
Dragon Ball plays the off angle and it
connects they've done it Potter always
comes into this with a bullet list of
things that she wants to get across her
team what's working what they're going
to change and preparing her team for
that and as soon as she gets done with
that the rest of the team is able to
start adapting to what she's saying I'm
looking at the a-hole as well
demon one sets up here he does not have
Dash anymore
I'm buying it now
calm's watching it guys
this is it this is how it ends
Zepp was the last one up look at
everyone going for it I want it I want
it the Flash and the kill delivers
light he can strike the same place twice
Evil Geniuses Welcome to Tokyo the
pressure was all sent off like we didn't
even expect to be here you know just the
other day we're watching mibr and let's
be honest that morning when we woke up
the chances of mibr winning that series
was slim tonight you're probably
thinking it had to lcq just like exactly
I mean so for us
um these last few days have been very
fast it's been kind of a blur but I'm
glad that our prep beforehand leading up
to this kind of kept us composed right
now despite shocking everyone with their
win in North America EG entered Masters
Tokyo as underdogs nobody knew how they
would fare against some of the world's
best but once they hit the stage EG
proved the naysayers wrong yet again are
they gonna swing off the Trailblazer
yeah they are there it is
caught on the wall
still pushing forward but that should
give foot a window to get out but can
busio hold them back himself they've got
him trapped there's nowhere for them to
go
Lucio playing such a dangerous position
and he gets two looking for the third
and fusio finds it
not able to convert on much more but
from the graves he brings Mr fallen down
with him it's contained well by Team
Liquid comb also going for another
[Applause]
way in hell how is he getting away with
that they can't be stopped Apparently
after that after witnessing that come
set out for the snake by preemptively
this time
but look at this comps found a little
bit of room to work that's durka removed
but he's still on the site mostly to get
back towards here back corner Ethan's
gonna trade out Leo it ain't over yet
but maybe Chronicle Maybe not maybe it's
Diva one he's got the nose out a 2v2 out
for a Chronicle to try and get fnatic
across the line oh my God he's
saved them but it's Alpha up against
demon now oh my God
but just moments away a 2v4
difficult to say the very least times
there
team one finally making it to the site
but Alpha waiting on the corner he wants
this done he wants some dead demon won
the last man standing a fnatic surely
now this moment is theirs 40 HP for
demon one and they're just not letting
him get that room they're not
entertaining the idea
Potter and EG went all the way to the
Grand finals and while they ultimately
fell short against fnatic their showing
in Tokyo will live on as one of the
greatest Cinderella runs valorent has
ever seen they went from a laughing
stock in their region getting 30 node in
the regular season two finalists on the
world stage and a large part of that
success can be credited to Potter she
was willing to make the difficult
decisions when it looked like all was
lost she was able to shrug off the
haters and critics and focus on exactly
what her team needed to do to win and no
matter what she never stopped believing
in her players I want to win something I
want to win either a split in a I want
to win I just want to win everything I
guess Potter's Legend is far from over
she showed everyone what she can do and
now she is just getting started
was that coffee it is a coffee it's like
I have the Starbucks I just turn uh the
caramel macchiato creamer I technically
shouldn't be drinking it for my heart
but it's the one thing I can't make an
exception on I'm like oh all Whole Foods
like I know this know that but the
caramel macchiato Kramer must stay in my
fridge